it's 100% a health care rate
women are 14 times more likely to die from pregnancy than an abortion
abortion bans increase the maternal mortality rate up to 21%
abortion bans increase the infant mortality rate
when we put in abortion bans
we create health care deserts
it has lost two
Idaho has lost two of its most valuable maternity wards
these it's not just a health care right
when you look at the impact on the individual
it is the impact that it has on society
47,000 women die every year attempting to get an abortion
they have to turn to unsafe abortions
and almost 50,000 women every single year die
forcing pregnancy on individuals has far worse outcomes
then giving them the care that they have already decided is what they need
we do not need to be questioning women on their needs
it has disastrous mental health outcomes
because you are forcing someone to go through this
it can k!ll you
and women will die in the United States
performing non consensual reproductive labor